today's topic do do cover trophy wife
has something to say during my time i'm
not sure what is like the hype right now
and it goes through like different
phases but during my short stint and um
the really extreme acts were what was
popular and that's why being the number
one performer in the industry at the
time
everyone wanted to make money off me so
they pushed me to do these things and
it just gets really extreme like you
were saying
ever feel like did you ever go through
those experiences where you had to do a
scene where it was very aggressive and
you just felt like
yeah i mean i don't want to go into too
much detail like honestly some of my
experiences are really humiliating for
me and i wish that they never happened
there's stuff going on like people
getting pissed on
men are pissing inside of women's
holes down their throats they're
sorry oh don't cry
told me something was sick
no i'm crying i'm like god damn it
no don't cry just giving some examples
but there's really just like crazy stuff
going on that damages people's bodies
for the rest of their lives i luckily
don't have any issues but i've seen
scenes shot in europe where
guys are literally punching into a
girl's [ __ ] like this
there's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] out there
hey listen
first off your punching technique is
trash but two
maybe it's
maybe it's the [ __ ] punching listen
this looked like jake paul in his first
fight that's not how you punch okay what
else but
it's punching for pleasure
punching the name of love i know
hey listen
somebody out there shout out to all the
ladies with [ __ ] big enough to pass
a train through it but listen i'm gonna
say this as far as it being a danger to
their body i don't disagree it's just a
conversation but again you're choosing
that for money the same way nfl players
are choosing to put their bodies on the
line to get concussions if you want to
have this conversation about well it's a
danger to their health they shouldn't be
allowed to do that we can say that about
a lot of work to what degree can people
put themselves at risk for money before
the rest of us what
i thought it was about to say to what
degree
can you punch someone's [ __ ]
i was just thinking what possesses a man
to see a booty hole and he's like
you know what i'm saying
you're not saying
what possesses a man to pull a ronda
rousey just be like
you remember that
ronda rousey do you imagine this guy
who's about to do it he's backstage
honestly i feel like i'm in denial
sometimes and i can't accept some of the
things that i've done
there is one thing that you know i tried
talking to a therapist about before
something that i had to do for a scene
that was really rough for me um
basically
this guy had a bowl and
said let me just tell you this whenever
you're watching a prawn video and a bowl
comes out nothing
nothing good's about to happen listen
nothing good you're not about to get no
tuna casserole no pumpkin pie all right
no mama's collard greens let me just
tell you okay or apple crumble okay
all right there might be a stew but it's
not the kind of stew you want to be
having something about to get crumble
okay
it ain't brownies i ain't your cookies
it's just brown it ain't cookies okay
okay it's not apple juice
but it's citrusy okay so i'm just
letting you guys know if you watch a
video
and they pull out a bow
or they pull out a wine glass
it's not going to end well
but let's play let's let's let me find
out this guy had a bowl and
he like gagged me until i threw up into
it and then he like pissed in the bowl
and during the scene he asked me to
drink it
stop for life
bishop look at this one stab eliza
i've taken time to do a little research
to find out what lana roads do in the
privacy of her bedroom
huh they have a practice called
vomit drinking
where a man proceeds to vomit into a
bowl
and then
he pees into the bowl and then he
inserts himself into the woman huh and
then he says to her i would like you to
drink it huh
and she drinks it
like a cat's
hajjat look at this one is this what
barack obama wants to bring to our
country as a human rights ambassador
for our children to drink the pipi
and the vomit
from the wine glass
all right cheese i told you i did not
know where this sea was going oh
how many people
are about to look up that seat some
people are about to you tell people
something nasty but they go
[Laughter]
today's video is sponsored oh wait
all right you already know
okay we're ready today's video is
sponsored by blue chew say it with us
now blue chip it's time for you to gain
more confidence and longer lasting
experiences in the bedroom with
bluetooth tablets okay you deserve
better she deserves harder listen
bluechu is a unique online service that
offers you
the same active ingredients as a viagra
in cialis but in a chewable form and at
a fraction of the cost and one of the
best parts is that you know blue chew
it's an online service so you don't need
to go to the doctor and have an awkward
conversation with that person all you
gotta do is go to bluetooth.com you just
need to consult with one of their
medical licensed professionals and once
you're approved we just ship it to your
door and we got a special deal just for
you guys you can try bluetooth for free
when you use promo code abba all right
and all you gotta do is pay for the five
dollar shipping that's bluechew.com
using promo code abba and get your first
month free so a big shout out to
bluetooth for sponsoring this video and
i didn't know how to say no it was one
of the most disgusting foul scenes
i ever had to do
and i'm telling a therapist this and
they don't even [ __ ] know what to say
to me yeah no one can relate like no one
[ __ ] knows what to say about it i
definitely can relate to that just even
by like working out hooters i know i
definitely was a sex object hooters
really [ __ ]
i just shared a disgusting story about
me having to drink piss out of a bowl
like a weltering labrador
and you want to relate to me
by talking about [ __ ] hooters
having to wear booty shorts and a crop
top
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
next time i get a chance i'm gonna put
some nasty [ __ ] in your spice pumpkin
latte
[ __ ] you like that's who i was viewed as
working at hooters
clearly i was the complete opposite of
that
girlfriend girlfriend you're doing a
disservice because when you walk inside
hooters for that job application okay
hooters is very
clear uh clear to send their logo they
they they're very clear those aren't our
eyes they are not in the first those
aren't owl eyes
your orientation that you do whenever
you work for hooters
some of my friends was working for
hooters
they're very clear about what they're
doing so
that was a corporate choice that you
made i'm sorry
nobody that works
for hooters
was coerced or would they know yeah if
you
if you got into that job you got into
that job you knew you were saying sanjay
oh that's
also
part of feminism and part of this new
age is that you can choose to be a sex
object and it's empowerment you choose
to get on instagram and post your
half-naked body and everyone's
supposedly supposed to accept it now
you're saying i worked at hooters where
i had to have my titties popping out my
turtleneck right and you want us to feel
bad guys you can't have it both ways you
can't say feminism is about giving women
choices and then say well there's a job
that wants people to be sex objects and
it's unacceptable what but you know i
definitely was pressured into some
things that i didn't want to do with men
um they had the audacity to ask me to
literally go give them a hand job behind
the dumpsters
yeah you know
it's not funny no it's like it's like
comical it's comical behind it good i
feel good
why because if she's laughing about that
i'm laughing about this yeah
so yeah so if it's comical because ccc
it was comical because you thought it
was comical yeah it depends on the
people it depends on you so if
the same way some things are
unacceptable for you some things you
know can be very much acceptable and let
me just tell you as far as being a sub
child it has nothing to do with you
working at hooters you could be at
[ __ ] mcdonald's so people like can i
get a hand job behind the dumpster this
is kind of the way it works
but they would they would push my limits
like they would just kind of joke around
at first or like oh um and they i'll
give you a touchy sometimes too you know
yeah and you know they were like oh i'll
give you a hundred dollars if you take
off your panties for me and you know i
was vulnerable i was young i was like oh
like no harm like okay like he just
wants my panties like heck yeah 100
we're good we're done bro bro bro bro i
swear to god okay
um
we're good okay
we we i think you prove your point
very much so from that last part i think
we could wrap it up should i have your
paintings for 100
sure take them no arm no huh guys are
bad i was a sex object it was bad wrap
it up wrap it up we wrap it up and i'm
not even gonna explain that [ __ ] wrap it
up guys if you guys are enjoying today's
video be sure to like and comment like
it like it comment it helps out that
algorithm you're watching it for free we
provide you with daily content just like
the video and if you like the merch get
them earned and if you want 50 of people
watch the videos and don't subscribe
stop it you're already here let's have a
good laugh and let's subscribe click
okay ring the bell and so when it
obviously so obviously i don't know how
like porn a shot they don't tell you
beforehand does this did they tell this
guy to do these things or did he just
get his own brain this one my agent was
actually very pissed about okay and
again like i'm not saying that i was i
but you were putting my spot i told this
guy like yeah i'm excited let's do this
i just i didn't know how to say no i i
didn't i just wanted everyone to be
happy so it's there's this thing now
where they're saying you know hey if
it's not an enthusiastic
yes
it's a no
her enthusiastic yes was clearly your no
yay i mean it's complicated because you
know when so much money is put in front
of you you often do things that you may
not feel great about after the fact but
you also have to take accountability for
the fact that you accepted it you know
what i'm saying and nobody could read
your mind
right
your values are constantly going to get
tested and what you're willing to do for
money is also going to get tested i'm
not saying there's not a slot of course
of power within the industry and there's
a lot to be discussed
i agree with that
but we also have to find the balance
between personal accountability and your
own values and that course of nature of
the industry right just because
something is super tempting you have to
take accountability for the fact that
you were tempted a really beautiful
woman has a tremendous amount of hold
over synth all right probably more so
than whatever she had to face within
that industry
trust me guys go bankrupt and lose their
whole lives over a beautiful woman it
happens every day
where do they deserve accountability for
the fact that they gave into that
temptation there's a discussion to be
had
okay but every time there's this framing
of like
frailty or
like oh this was terrible the way that
you were of course it's always centered
around the female experience so no
that's honestly that's really hard and i
think like i had mentioned earlier it's
just so important for young men to stop
you being stop viewing women as sex
objects because i believe that you know
instilling that curriculum in school at
a younger age and they had actually said
there's a fact that says that the more a
young person had learned about the use
of pornography from their school
education or sex education is less
likely to see women as sex objects and i
feel that's why you know i
i feel so passionate about the industry
because i don't believe that they should
be showing those types of scenes because
it does view women as just an object and
it's not okay to do that like i enjoy
watching
like girl like i you know but like i
want to watch ethical porn i wanted to
be normalized and i wanted to be taught
to where
it shouldn't be to where a woman is
being
is you know like that the male is
showing aggression because that actually
is going to translate into his
relationships with women in the future
okay
there's a fine line to cut here is it
because someone does something degrading
in a video that is there for
abuse no no
okay so my question is listen i know
folks who who work in the adult industry
right they get paid to go out and do
services right powerful men will pay
them they come in right the guy's laying
the bathtub they get a little brownie
surprise that's not porn that's not
prawn that's not my point my whole point
is it's the act okay all right the act
of doing that right these ladies get
paid to do that yeah some people like to
be degraded some people want to see
folks get degraded okay that is an
industry and you would agree that that
industry isn't inherently bad because
some people just have kinks like that we
agree there has to be a bit of a balance
here we can't have this kind of sex
positive thing where we say everyone's
kinks are to be represented cool right
but then at the same time say wait this
pineapple is bad because what it teaches
young men is this well a lot of it is
like young boys don't understand and
they think that this is normal and
that's what girls want so they've
probably never been with a girl before
and they see these horrible things and
they're like oh this is how to please a
girl this is what i have to do this is
what she wants and then they you know do
these things and they act certain ways
and they don't realize the effects that
they're having on women
see the other problem with this is some
women do like that as somebody who's
super vanilla i've encountered women who
like yo listen
listen
i've had to do things that i wasn't very
comfortable with okay
um
you know things were slapped all right
not with my hand and
things were wet slapped
oh
and
okay
things i've never done in my life listen
i i had to spit into things that i
didn't understand
whatever you know it's their pleasure
what can i want me to spit in your eye
what man rough
there's some freaks out here in these
streets okay but i understand that's
what they're into i'm not gonna be like
it's because some trauma from your
childhood like i don't know why she's
into that i think it's gross but she
likes it so i'm gonna do it so i think
we need to stop saying like well guys
listen there's ladies who like this kind
of stuff there's super submissive ladies
who like the grading stuff
and so when you say this you're really
misrepresenting what's actually
happening out there i've stumbled upon
some videos where i'm not gonna lie i
really questioned why is this even
allowed on the internet like i felt very
like i was just
turned off i was like
shut my laptop like i can't even look at
this i was like i cannot believe that
this is okay like this is not okay to
treat women like this i could not get
off to this i don't know who watches
this too some people have that fetish
and it's crazy that's why they put it
out there because they're like oh
somebody will watch it which is
just like yeah offense but like that's
disgusting because obviously she's not
okay don't you realize
that the exact same people thing that
you're saying about these folks people
would say about lana doing any kind of
prawn yeah
that's disgusting she's not okay what
kind of woman would choose to do adult
work period
hey uh so this is what we think all
right tell us what you think and don't
forget we have a patreon that you can
subscribe uh there's cool stuff on there
exclusive stuff exclusive videos we have
other videos coming up check it out
there's always there's also the merch
you know i've been preached you can
check it out and yeah tell us what you
think in the comments
[Music]
ring my